la scène s'est multipliée un peu partout
au pays
bien sûr d'oublier de restera à la
maison au bureau et également je sais
pas si à votre bureau vous aviez des
téléviseurs ouvert entre nous est vide a
pas beaucoup de télévision ici dans une
salle de nouvelles
les gens ont avons le arrêté de
travailler pour quelques minutes
bref l'engouement est à peu près à son
compte et ce qui est particulier cette
année c'est que sur le web ou si ça
explose uniquement sur les plateformes
web mobile de radio-canada siby 6 900
mille connexions plus de 900 milles près
d'un million aujourd'hui seulement
frédéric arnold la fierté canadienne à
son maximum avec ses fameux bonnet à
pompon
mais impossible d'en trouver chez le
seul vendeur autorisé la bégude sont
même sur son site internet
seule solution en acheter sur ebay mise
à prix jusqu'à 200 dollars
celle ci est prête à en payer le prix
pour encourager l'équipe canadienne
senior de nombreux exemples de cette
ferveur qui enflamme les bars de
montréal à toronto jusqu'à vancouver où
même le décalage horaire de 8 9 ou même
12 heures
n'empêche pas la bière très matinal
partout le canada retient son souffle
au gré des victoires et des médailles le
plan d'action du canada de stephen
harper s'est même arrêté priorité au
hockey
le décalage horaire semble toutefois
avoir pesé sur l'audience des réseaux de
télévision car celle ci est en baisse
par rapport aux jeux de vancouver
pourtant selon le cio il y à 464 chaînes
de télévision qui diffusent les jeux
alors qu'en 2010 il y en avait que 240
les cotes d'écouté à la télévision
peuvent subir un lent déclin lente
érosion
mais au total tout on n'a jamais rejoint
autant de perdus parce qu'on aura
compris bien sûr que celui qui autrefois
ne pouvait pas regarder les jeux
olympiques au travail peut maintenant le
faire et c'est précisément ce qui arrive
sur l'ordinateur
une application web ouvertes et puis ne
suiviez à peu près tous les commerces et
bureaux sont pris d'assaut par les jeux
avec une certaine baisse de productivité
mais une hausse de la fierté
et peu importe l'heure même les écoles
ne sont pas en reste plus de 32 millions
de canadiens ont un moment ou un autre
regarder du contenu en un clic sur une
plateforme de siby 6 ou de radio canada
près du quart d'entre eux l'ont fait sur
leur téléphone ou leur tablette donc la
ferveur se modernise elles se
multiplient et les jeux ne sont même pas
terminé
imaginons
un comble